that's trying to regroup the composer
dispossession
Pastor Gary lead for the next Paris
drives in rejected by Robinson he got it
with his wrists step in Dudley flicks it
to Harris back for Dudley who lays it in
it just passed a mismatch down low with
Harrison Robinson knocks just put it up
instead of passing it Dudley steps into
it and put it on the board four three
two his coaching staff he's very
perceptive as we know he's been around
the league suddenly gives it up the spin
talon the finish with the offhand
it's an 801 to start the season to a
quicker hurry mode both more than
getting it there at 18 seconds of
getting it going that time Russell work
that gets the aggression of Indiana he
leads the lead more than Cleveland in
security guards oh no no that's one of
the things they take the most pride in
this happening security guards they can
have in Napier
it was probing backdoor does kick it
corner did woody count it that's that
ball moving great backdoor cut great pad
an offensive push they had late first
quarter into the second worst shooting
just 33% Johnson citizen on a scoop
NIC's and Kenny Atkins have talked about
wanting more energy and for grittiness
from his guys lot of movement for
Brooklyn did when he gets the step
corner Dudley
nobody will remember the face unless you
make the shot
thank goodness for charity Dudley has it
ricochet back to the Allen is better to
us stomach
Mifflin play by Jared Dudley Dudley
drives nice
the throw runneth over there's any
further update we will get it for you
quick let's go Dudley has to heat put
city Dudley kicks it out Russell shooter
and he has been spectacular this year
from beyond the arc
how is Jefferson cutting in on the feed
from Dudley's best lettuce ISM some size
and bounce but you will be aggressive on
the offensive end
Harris good look at a connection that's
his spot
crosses over on Harris help from Allen
and he turns it over to for one
opportunity here for the nets
Dinwiddie pull-up three bottom here in
the fourth
Russell gets around uber aw3 and Dudley
mop the three-point line what is he
doing back cuts quick
Dudley makes a cut gives it up Davis off
a cat a deuce job by Jared Dudley
creating something and that's where the
Nets at the rookie Luke advantage this
season but early on last season it was
Dennis Smith junior and his explosive
dog Lee gets it to go and a foul
you're almost expected here fake handoff
you almost expect them to just as a stat
the Nets have lost 10th street new tips
roll to the rim Dudley
jared dudley tough delivery to get the
scoring start its point lead for the
t-wolves the Angela Russell has been
held to three points Dudley will he get
it
he will chance at a three-point play and
one for cuddly just called it out drag
fakes the handoff goes through finishes
yeah and points 34 31 Cleveland Dudley
gives it up Davis sit down
[Applause]
great job of splitting the pick-and-roll
they thought it was going to be a
dribble handoff and then an excellent
collapse on that first penetration by
Kawhi Leonard
Joe Harris the finish off the bench in
this first Dudley I attack up underneath
on the delivering from Dinwiddie Dudley
on the drive lays it up and in and gets
the bump from Berger it could be a
three-point play
there's nothing Jared Dudley loves more
than a fake dribble handoff and the
rookie three minutes just want to keep
trying to take advantage of this time of
him
Jared Dudley puts the nets in front by
10 the fake on kuzmic Huber Chico
rebound
Dudley is there polish Jefferson clears
it
Dudley to the rim
I'm out Harris leaves it for Russell
shot clock winding down the cut school
Jared Dudley Russell gives up his
dribble once again it's doubling under a
minute to go
Dudley fire
[Music]
using on it when you see these switches
there's little miscommunication Jared
Dudley has driven that that little
stream multiple times tonight while a
bucket 63-61 pulls Dinwiddie kick for
Dudley Jared Dudley Russell switch now
it's Russell against Portis handles back
door
Dudley leaves it for Davis layup goes
well executed by Brooklyn his watch this
Russell - Dudley a wide open Ed Davis
because he draws in last Nets lead was
nine eight didn't woody keep it moving
Dudley fire
nice pass from Joe Harris Dudley again
with a lofty shot still an emotional
shet game because of the holidays
because the off dates coming up is Davis
weights and bounds it down good boys for
Matt Davis
Dudley just lays it to him and there it
is
bang and he finishes that a little
faster if I could have gotten away with
that it's not much stuff
Darleen shovels Davis finishes nice
delivery from Dudley so here comes
Dudley around the corner and watch Davis
in traffic right now not gathering it
easily but going up with a few people
swinging at him
trying to get the deflection time to
drop for that right shot Dinwiddie high
off the window ku roots kept it alive
Dudley Allen for the slow down the floor
and then Allen's turn to finish one off
after the good pass by Dudley now per
gallon is ready for a three-point shot
over there
Dudley kicks to roots hits
there's an adjustment on the fly Kenny
Atkins it's last great bang to the deck
EE balls fake down the middle
hollis-jefferson
flex it rondae hollis-jefferson using
the window shot clock at five
out of the timeout Dinwiddie to Allen
kicks Dudley at three he's got it
jared dudley from the long reign three
and a half to play in double overtime
dinner woody gets the step on Parker
Dudley from the corner so on the way
they really managed the floor
Dudley from the corner with about seven
ticks left on the clock back into this
game with that 2-3 zone they primarily
been playing that since the end of the
first day the veterans spending by Jared
Dudley you see there Dudley showing
right past jeremy land here
hops inside Dudley run off Allen on the
cut and the finish Jared Allen invited
Lake it's probably could've taken that
three-point shot ed Dudley tees it up
knocks it down
sit down emphatically on multiple poles
Jared moments ago this was awesome
beautiful delivery by Jared Dudley and
then I just the force that he put that
down
Dudley to the do it don't always do
strive and kick ku roots for the shot
clock winding down
Dudley state cutter kudos nice team
basketball for Brooklyn
Tara Stern supporter he thought Alan was
going to be there Lin
[Applause]
he got him clean continued to impress
her thought he was going to have just a
clearer look at the basket whether it's
high whether its scrapped
[Music]
it's now that puts it in got a mouse in
the house a little contact and maternal
Hawaii okay see how you wanted he won
the pout but they've been a number of
hits at that end where Jared Dudley the
sage veteran off the bench
yeah just keep an eye on New Jersey now
see they'll rush the ball up the floor
quickly and shoot three Nets can cut it
to single digits here ten points in the
corner already for hollis-jefferson
Dudley splashes a three we hope you
didn't go to bed it's a single digit
deficit
and the push hollis-jefferson finds his
own copan teammate infox looking to
answer to God rebelled Brooklyn they can
take the lead here
how is Jefferson finds Russell Dudley
top of the key three Buckland leads by
two started with the pass out by Hollis
Jefferson and DeAngelo Russell would
think he got off to a hot start
here's levert Dudley Catching Fire eggs
hit push the foul you get looks from the
three-point line the question will be
can they knock them down excellent job
of Jared Dudley Flynn defense by Kara
sliver what a closeout on current Dudley
delivers Davis finishes plus the foul
beautiful play early offense getting
things going out of the transition like
the Grady talking about it just before
tip as Dudley sets himself up to three
bits nice response to look like football
is the most intimidating defender when
you're trucking it inbounded Dudley does
Russell
the closet in he's five of five a
three-point territory guard the man
Levert trata answer
terrorism
dete Hill against Dudley a lot of
dribbler Fraser knocked away
Dudley gives it up Graham tribe to the
RAM Tippin goes trailing is Jared Dudley
for to Dublin yeah and take a look here
gets in front of Fraser cuts them off
gets the steal tries to get it ahead to
treyvion Graham and then just a smart
play looks at the clock gets the step on
Kannada no look Dudley pump fake veteran
savvy Jared Dudley six point lead they
blitz levert totally gets the steps
dishes Davis throws it down veteran to
veteran way with a couple earlier
tonight well in what a job here is just
the Dudley's did what he vacates the
area now they switch that door not the
right feed by sabonis did woody
directing traffic
Dudley straightaway three
Dudley drives kicks Graham will get a
three off and three beyond Graham from
long distance witty on the drive Carol
jugglers cuts to the rim high-speed the
Davis van took some steps but he get to
the basket the next dead ball
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Joelle and be it sit-ins they've had a
war of words and when the three isn't
going he's been cutting for some boxer
ting levert into the starting lineup
here's the back
[Applause]
he has been proved hard every time he's
touched to the point what it finished by
Allen what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content